[MUSIC PLAYING]
METE ATAMEL: Hello, my
name is Mete Atamel.
I'm a developer
advocate at Google,
and today I want to go
through a code lab with you.
The name of the
code lab is build
event-driven orchestration
with Eventarc and workflows.
Now, as you can see,
there's two key phrases
in the title, event-driven
and orchestration.
So let's zoom into
those a little bit
before we dive into the codelab.
When you have multiple
services, at some point
these services
need to communicate
and you need to decide
how they will communicate.
One easy way is services to
call each other directly.
So you can have service
A call service B. Service
B can call service C,
and so on and so forth.
This is easy to implement, but
it creates unnecessary coupling
between services.
So if you need to
change service B,
you need to know that
service A is calling it
and you need to
know that it calls
service C, so you need to
think about those dependencies.
Now, to make it more loosely
coupled, what you can do
is you can use an
event-driven approach.
In an event-driven architecture,
services, they do their work,
and when they are finished,
they just emit an event.
That even goes to
a message broker,
and the message
worker figures out
which other services
care about this message
and it passes it on.
And then the next
service does its work,
and it will just
emit another message.
In this event-driven
model, services
don't know about
each other and they
don't care about each other.
Instead, they just
consume messages
and they emit messages.
This allows more loosely
coupled kind of architecture,
and it makes it easier
to change services
without having to think about
the next services in the chain.
At the same time,
it also makes it
hard to trace your architecture.
So if something goes
wrong, for example,
if an event cannot be processed
or if the service goes down,
it will be difficult to figure
out exactly where things are
not working.
Now, a third approach
is called orchestration.
In orchestration, you
have an external service,
an orchestrator,
where you define
how the services should
be called, in what order,
and the orchestrator is
responsible for making sure
that the services are called and
then the result is being taken
and that result is passed
to the next service.
Now, in orchestration, you
basically bring some order
to your service to
service communication,
and it makes it easier to
trace if something goes wrong.
Now, in this code lab, we are
combining both approaches.
We are combining event-driven,
and we are also combining
orchestration with it.
And the reason for that
is that in some use cases,
you want the structure
provided by orchestration,
so you want certain
services to be orchestrated
because you want
to make sure they
are called in a certain order.
But at the same time, you don't
want your whole architecture
to be an orchestration.
Instead, you can have the
orchestration be triggered
by an event, in a
loosely coupled way,
or you can also have the
orchestration send an event
at the end of the orchestration.
This allows the best
of both worlds, where
you have some
things orchestrated
but the other orchestrations
are communicating
in a loosely coupled way.
So that's what we're going to
build today in this code lab,
and let's just go ahead and
get started with the code lab.
OK, so I have the
code lab on the left,
and I also have the Google
Cloud Console on the right.
But let's look at
the code lab first.
You should have the
link in the description.
And what we're going to
do is, as I mentioned,
we're going to build an
event-driven orchestration
with Eventarc and workflows.
Eventarc, it's a service
from Google Cloud that
allows you to connect
different services,
so you can connect
different event sources
to a different
event destination.
And Eventarc makes
it really easy,
by just basically
creating a trigger.
So we're going to use that
for the event-driven part
of the code lab.
Now, for orchestration,
we're going
to be using workflows,
which is an orchestration
service for Google Cloud.
And workflows allows you
to orchestrate pretty much
any kind of public
HTTP endpoint.
So this can be on HTTP on
Cloud Run or Cloud Functions,
or anywhere, actually,
not even on Google Cloud.
It can be outside
of Google Cloud.
Workflows can bring that
into an orchestration.
And that's what we're
going to use, as well.
And then for our
code, we're going
to be using Cloud Functions.
So we're going to be deploying
four Cloud Functions that
do different things.
And in the end,
we'll build an app
where we will orchestrate these
functions using workflows,
but we'll connect that
orchestration to Google Cloud
Storage events using Eventarc.
And I'm going to talk
more about the application
in the next steps.
But as an overall
architecture, this
is what we have, some
Cloud Functions that
are orchestrated, and
they get triggered
by an event from Cloud Storage.
Now, before we start, we have
some setup and requirements,
so let's go through
them in Step 2.
So first, you need a
Google Cloud project, OK?
And you also need
a billing account.
So if you have a
Google Cloud project
and if you have billing
attached to that project, great,
you can just use
that if you like.
But we also have this-- we are
also giving you some credits.
So if you go to this link,
gcpcredits.com/io2022,
let's click on that.
This takes you to a
page where you need
to log in with a Gmail account.
And then once you do that,
you can click on Click Here
to Access Your Credits.
And you will see your
first name and last name,
and then there's a coupon code.
And then if you
accept and continue,
what this does is that it
creates a billing account
with some credits for you, OK?
I won't do this, because
I already have my setup.
But once you do this, you
will have a billing account
with some credits.
And then later, you can
attach that billing account
to your existing
projects, or you can also
create a new project and
use that billing account.
And I'll actually show you this
on my Google Cloud Console,
so let's switch here.
You see that I have a project,
but if I go to my billing,
I will manage my
billing accounts
and you will see that I
have two billing accounts.
The first one is Google Cloud
platform trial billing account.
So this is the
billing account that
will be created for you after
you go through this process.
I also have another billing
account for my own projects.
So you can pick
and choose whatever
you want, but this
credit is basically
for you to be able
to do the code lab
if you don't have
billing set up.
But if you already
have billing set up,
you can also use that, as well.
OK, so that's that.
So once you have
the billing set up,
next step is to actually
either select a project
or use a project or
create a project.
So it's up to you.
If you have an existing
project, you can use that.
But also, if you
want something fresh,
you can start from
a new project.
So here, let me just
create a project just
to show you how this works.
So here I am, as you can
see, in Google Cloud Console,
and I have multiple
projects already set up.
But what I'm going
to do is I'm just
going to click on New
Project here and let's
give this a name, event--
let's call this
event-driven-orchestration.
And then for the
billing account,
if you redeemed what
we told you earlier,
then you will have this.
Or if you have an
existing billing account,
you can use that, as well.
I'll just choose my
existing billing account.
And I don't need to
choose organization.
so I'll just hit Create.
And now a new project is
being created for us, OK?
So you can do this, as well,
or if you have an existing
project, you can just
select it from here
and make sure that
you are in a project.
So we have that, and we'll
make a note of the project ID
because we will use that
throughout the code lab.
So the project ID, you
can see it from here.
So when you have your projects,
the ID is listed here,
and you can see it from there.
All right, so that's our
project and billing set up.
Now next, we're
going to be using
Cloud Shell to do the code lab.
So to interface
with Google Cloud,
you have a couple of options.
You can either download
Google Cloud SDK,
and that gives you a
gcloud command line tool.
And with that tool, you can
basically use your laptop
and use gcloud to interface
with Google Cloud, if you like.
And you can certainly
do that, if you like.
But you can also
use Cloud Shell,
which is a terminal
within the browser.
It gives you a terminal
It's easier, because we are
already in Google Cloud Console
and we can have a terminal here,
and we can do everything here.
So that's what I'm going to use.
But before we get
there, let me make sure
that our project is created.
So here, the event-driven
orchestration
is here, so I'll just
select a project.
It's not finished loading
yet, so let me refresh
and let me switch
to my other account.
So you need to make sure that
you're in your right account
if you are using multiple
accounts, like me.
And you also want to make
sure that the project that you
created shows up in the list.
It's not showing up yet, so
let me refresh one more time.
And select all.
Yeah, I think the project
is created, but yeah, let's
go here and select Project.
OK, now I'm in the right place.
So that's why it's important
to make sure that you
are in the right place.
So you can see that I'm in
event-driven-orchestration
project, and it's
just recently created.
Now that I'm here, you
want to go to Cloud Shell.
So the Cloud Shell
is right here.
So you click on
Activate Cloud Shell.
And now this gives you basically
a virtual machine in the cloud.
Now it's being initialized.
And once it's
initialized, you will
be able to run commands
within the browser right here.
So we'll wait for that.
And by the way, you will have
some space on your Cloud Shell
to get some code
or save some files.
It's really a full
development environment,
with an editor and things like
that so you can do everything
from the browser.
It's very useful for code labs,
and also for just quick editing
all your projects.
So depending on the
time of the day,
sometimes it takes a
little bit of time to--
Cloud Shell to allocate
you a virtual machine.
But as you can see, we already
have it here, which is great.
Now, I'm going to make
this a little bit bigger.
Now, we need to
set up some things.
We're going to be needing
project ID throughout the code
lab, so let's make sure
that we set the project
ID to our actual project ID.
And in this case,
my project ID is--
actually, my project
ID is a little bit
different than the
name, so I'm just
going to copy and paste that.
And it's important
to note that the name
and the idea of the project
is not the same as always.
So sometimes it's the same.
Sometimes it's not
the same, so here you
need to make sure that you are
using the idea of the project.
So I'll do that.
And then the next
thing is the region.
So we're going to be deploying
services to different regions,
and you can choose any
region that Cloud Function is
supported.
So if you look at
this page there's
many locations where Cloud
Functions are supported.
In this case, I'm just
going to use US Central 1.
You can pick and choose
whatever you like.
And we will also
set these on gcloud,
so I'll just copy and paste this
gcloud config set core project,
and also gcloud config set.
I may need to authorize
for the first time
functions and region.
So this will set this project
ID and region in gcloud.
And if I actually do
a gcloud config list,
you should see that our
function region is set
and our project ID is also set.
This makes it easier when
we run commands later, OK?
So that's that.
And then we also need
to enable some services.
So let me clear this and let
me just copy and paste this,
and I'll explain what they are.
So let's copy and paste.
Because in Google
Cloud by default,
the services are not enabled,
so we need to enable them.
We're going to need
artifactregistry and cloudbuild
because we're going to
be building functions,
and for functions
you need these.
Then we need to enable
the functions API,
so that's what we do here.
We need to enable
Eventarc for eventing.
Vision API that we're
going to use in our code.
And then finally,
we need to enable
a couple of workflows APIs so
that we can do orchestration,
right?
So these are the things that
we need and, we enable them.
So you should see this
operation successful at the end.
So yeah, so this is all the
setup that we need to do.
The next thing is to
get the source code.
So the functions,
we don't have time
to write them from scratch.
Instead, the code
is already on GitHub
and we're just going
to sync to that GitHub
and just take a look at it.
So we'll do that.
So let me make sure I don't--
I actually already have this,
so I'm going to delete that.
And we're going to-- so there's
this Eventarc samples repo.
Let me just actually open
that and show it to you.
This is on GitHub,
where we have a number
of samples for Eventarc
and workflows and things.
But the one that we
are interested in
is under processing pipelines
folder and under here, you
will see that there's
image-v1, image-v2. image-v3.
These are different
versions of the app.
We're going to be
actually deploying
the version 3, the latest
version of this app,
but this is where
the code will live,
and we'll look at it
as we go along, OK?
So what I will do is
I will go back to--
let's close these.
I will go back to
here, and then we'll
just clone the source code.
So we'll clone the
Eventarc samples repo,
and then we'll go
to Eventarc samples
in our processing
pipelines folder, right?
So that's where we are, and
we see the different image
processing pipelines.
OK, so this is set
up and requirements.
So we set up our gcloud.
We set our
environment variables.
We got the code.
Now, before proceeding
further, let's
actually talk about what
we're going to build,
so that you have an idea
on what kind of application
we are building.
OK, so that's Step 3.
Let's make this smaller.
So what we are
building here, it's
an image processing pipeline.
The idea is that users save an
image to a Cloud Storage bucket
and then we have a
number of services
that will act on that image,
it will take that image,
it will resize that image,
it will label that image,
and it will
watermark that image,
and they will save them to
this output bucket, right?
So an image comes in, and
then it gets transformed
in multiple ways
and that image will
be saved to the output folder.
So that's the application
image processing pipeline.
And the way it flows is that
first, user saves the image
to a storage bucket.
That will trigger an event,
a new object creation event.
And that event will be
picked up by Eventarc Cloud
Storage trigger, so that
event will be picked up
and it will be passed
to a workflow, OK?
This workflow, it's an
image processing workflow.
Also, you can think of
it as an orchestration.
And it will get
that event and then
it will call some Cloud
functions in such an order.
So it will call a
filter function first,
then it will call
the labeler function,
and the function
will label the image
and save it to
that output bucket.
Then it will call the resizer
bucket to resize the image
and save it to
the output bucket.
And it will also
call the watermarker
to watermark the image and save
it to the output bucket, right?
And why is this
event-driven orchestration?
Because we have
these functions that
need to be called in a certain
order with certain parameters,
and we put those in
orchestration with workflow.
So this is an orchestration
that we'll go through later.
But at the same time,
it's event-driven
because the event from Cloud
Storage through Eventarc
is starting this orchestration.
So it's loosely
coupled in that sense,
that an event triggers it
in a loosely coupled way,
but this user doesn't know
that there's an orchestration
and then the orchestrator
doesn't know, really.
It just gets an event
through workflows.
So that's the event-driven
orchestration part of it.
Yeah, so this is what
we're going to build.
And the way we're going
to build this is at first
we're going to
deploy the functions.
So we will deploy
filter, labeler, resizer,
and watermarker.
And then we're going
to put them together
into an orchestration
with workflows,
so that we will kind of tie them
together into an orchestration.
And then finally, we'll
connect that orchestration
to the Cloud Storage events
using Eventarc trigger, OK?
So we'll kind of build it
backwards from this side
to the left side.
All right, and as you see,
we have the input bucket
and the output bucket.
So the next step, in step 4 is
actually creating this bucket.
So let's do that, actually.
Let's create these buckets
before we do anything else.
So I'll just switch back to our
Cloud Shell let's do a clear.
And I will just copy
and paste this code.
So the bucket names in Google
Cloud have to be unique.
So what I'm doing is that I'm
taking the project ID, which
is unique, and adding -images
input for the input bucket
and -images output
for the output packet.
And I'm using GSU tool to
create it from console.
You can also do it
from here, if you like.
But if you look at Cloud
Storage, under here,
now that we run this, we see
two buckets, an input and output
bucket, right?
So they're created.
So these will be the inputs and
outputs to our architecture.
Now next, we want to
deploy the filter service.
So let's-- before we do that,
let's go back to architecture
over here.
So we created the buckets.
Now let's deploy the filter
service, the first service
that we want to deploy.
And before I show you
the code, let me actually
run this deployment script.
So let's run this.
And as it's deploying,
I want to explain to you
what this function does.
So let's-- I'm sorry, let me
clear this and let's paste it.
And OK.
And as this is happening, let's
look at the filter function.
So the filter function,
the code is on GitHub
it's a C sharp function,
So it's written in C sharp,
but it can be any language
that Cloud functions support,
like Node.js or Python
or anything else.
But the function itself,
it's an HTTP function,
so it receives HTTP calls.
And the first thing that
you're going to realize
is that the function
is extracting
the bucket and the file
information from the event.
So it will receive an
event from workflows,
and that event will have the
bucket and file information,
the actual file, basically, that
triggered this event, so it's
extracting that.
Then it's calling
a method called
is picture safe with
the URL of the file.
And if you look at the picture,
is picture safe method,
it's using Vision client.
So this is a Vision API
client on Google Cloud.
And it's calling detect
saved search async.
So it's basically making a call
to a Vision API and saying,
is this image with
this URL safe or not.
And this returns
some likelihoods.
So what we are looking
at is basically
we are checking
if the response is
adult, medical, spoof, violence,
and if it's likely or not.
So it's not likely at all, we
conclude that the picture is
safe, so we turn true.
Otherwise, we conclude that
the picture might not be safe,
so we return false, OK?
So once we have this
safe field flagged,
the reply data, so what we
reply back from this function
is simple Boolean, maybe just
say safe equals true or false,
all right?
So that's all this
function does.
It receives the file
event, and then it
checks whether it's safe and
it returns a response that says
this picture is safe or not.
Quite simple, OK?
And the way we deploy this is
we use gcloud functions deploy,
so we are deploying this
as a Cloud function.
We're making it a public
function, although it
doesn't have to be public.
You should probably have private
functions from workflows.
Runtime is dotnet3,
because this is a dotnet C
sharp kind of function.
It's HTTP triggered.
Region is US central.
We deploy to US central,
and this is the entry point
or our function.
And we also pass in built
environment variables
because our function
has some dependencies
outside the immediate folder.
That's why I'm calling
it from this top level
folder, processing pipelines.
And since I'm calling
it from a top level
folder with common
libraries, I need
to pass in this
environment variable
to tell Cloud functions where
the actual code is, right?
That's what it is trying to do.
So you can see
that it's deployed
and it has a URL, this function.
So we're going to need that URL.
So that's why I have this
filter URL environment
variable that I'm going
to set, because we're
going to need it later.
So it just gets that.
And if I do--
I call it filter
URL, you can see
that I have the URL of the
filter function, basically.
OK, so this is the
first function deployed.
Next, we're going to deploy
labeler, so that's step 6.
So let's go to step 6.
Again, it's the same
kind of deployment.
So I'm going to kick
off the deployment
before I show you the code.
So let's make sure
that that starts.
And let's take a look
at the labeler function.
Now, the labeler function, it's
exactly the same as before.
It's a C sharp
function that has--
it's an HTTP function, as well.
But what it's going to
do is slightly different.
So it still receives the
event, the file event.
But this time, it will call
an extract label method.
And in this extract label,
we use Vision API again,
so this is a Vision client.
And we call DetectLabels async.
This extracts the
labels out of the image
using machine learning, OK?
So it will get the
labels of the image.
And we are getting 10
results, because we
don't need more than 10.
And then we order
them with their score
and we return the
ordered labels.
So we had the labels here.
And then what we
do afterwards is
first we save these
labels to a text
file with the name of
the file -labels.txt,
and we save all of
them to a text file.
So all 10 labels, we
send them to a text file
and we upload them to
Google Cloud Storage.
And then we also extract
the top three labels
and we return them as the
reply data from the function.
So the function will return
these top three labels
as the output, basically.
So you can see
that we are storing
the full labels in
a text file in case
you want to take a look, but
we are returning the top three
labels as the reply data.
And that will be
used by orchestration
later that I'm going to
show you how it's used.
So that's the next service,
the labeler service,
and we're going to need
the URL of this service,
as well, because we're going to
use it from the orchestration.
So we'll save that, as well,
once this function is deployed.
I'm just going to copy this,
and once this is deployed,
we'll get that, as well.
So let me actually go here
and go to Cloud Functions
just to see that the functions
that have been deployed.
So you can see that the filter
and labeler functions are
already deployed,
and let's make sure
that we get the labeler URL.
There we go, [INAUDIBLE] later.
And if I do echo
labeler URL, you
see that the labeler
URL is there.
So that's good.
All right, so back
to architecture.
We deployed filter.
We deployed labeler.
And the next one is resizer.
So let's deploy the
resizer service.
Again, the same kind of deal.
Let's copy the resizer
and kick the deployment
before I explain to
you what it does.
And with resizer, as
the name suggests--
let's look at the code--
it resizes the images.
So the function,
again, an HTTP function
that receives the bucket and
the file, just like before.
But this time, it downloads the
image from the Cloud Storage.
Then it uses a library to
resize that image to width
and the height that we specify.
And in this case, the width
and height is 400 to 400.
So we resize it in this code.
Then we save the file as the
name of the file -400.PNG.
Then we upload the image
back to Cloud Storage.
And then we reply back with
the bucket and the file
of the resized image, OK?
So we upload the
image, and we also say,
OK, this is the
image that I resized,
and this is the bucket and
the file of the resized image.
And again, we're going to use
this data from orchestration.
So you can see that in these
functions, it's very simple.
Like, they receive an event and
they do one thing at a time.
And that's the
beauty of functions.
You don't need to
do many things.
Actually, you shouldn't
You just do one thing at a
time, and once you're done,
you just reply back
with your reply.
And that said, there's not much
complicated logic in functions,
and you don't want
complicated logics,
because if you put a lot
of stuff in a function,
it will be hard to
maintain, because you
need to do everything in a
single function, basically.
All right.
So that's the resizer.
That's the resizer, and once
it's deployed, which happened,
we'll also get the resizer URL.
And we're going to
need that again later.
All right, so
that's the resizer.
And let's go back to
architecture overview.
The last one is watermarker,
here the function.
That's the last one that
we're going to deploy.
So we go to step 8.
And again, I will copy
this to start the process
of deploying watermarker.
All right, so as
this is happening,
let's look at the
code with watermarker.
And watermarker is probably
the most interesting function
out of all, because it kind of
combines all the information
from the previous steps.
So what happens in watermarker
is that this time, watermarker
receives more information than
just the bucket and the file.
The watermarker will receive
the bucket and the file
of the resize image,
but it will also
receive the labels of the image
from the previous function,
right?
So it receives those.
It downloads the resized
image from Cloud Storage,
then it uses a library to apply
a watermark, basically a text
on the file with the
labels that it received.
So you can see here we are
applying a simple watermark,
and we are passing the
labels that we received
from the previous function.
So we apply that
watermark, save it as JPEG,
and then we save the file
name -watermark JPEG,
and then we upload that
file back to Cloud storage.
OK, so combining
basically everything
that we see in the resize
image and the labels
into a new image, and we upload
that back to Cloud Storage.
And you can look
at the code, if you
like, in terms of how we do
this watermarking, if you want.
All right, so once
this is done, we'll
also have a watermarker URL
that we're going to need.
So I'm going to
save that, as well.
And then we'll be
done with functions.
I mean, the functions
will be deployed,
but they don't know
about each other.
They don't call each other.
They just exist on
their own, so we
need to bring them together into
some kind of an orchestration.
And for that, we're
going to use workflow.
But I will wait for watermarker
to be deployed first so we
can proceed with the next step.
And also you want to make sure
that once all your services are
deployed, just make sure
that they show up here.
I will go-- let's go to--
let's go home and come
back later once everything
is deployed.
And usually the functions,
they take a couple of minutes,
but sometimes it might
take a little bit longer.
So we'll just wait a few
seconds before we check.
All right, so that's
deployed, as well.
And before I forget, let
me get the watermarker URL.
So we got that.
And if I go to
Cloud Functions, I
see that there's four functions,
filter, labeler, resizer,
watermarker.
They are all deployed.
They're all running,
so everything is good.
Now we can go to our
architecture overview.
Now we need to bring them
together into an orchestration
so that they are called
in the order that we
defined and the arguments
are passed along
and things like that.
So that's step 9.
And to define
workflow, you're going
to use Google Cloud workflow
service, workflow service,
and you need to define
that in YAML or JSON.
So we have this
workflow.yaml file.
If you go back to
our Cloud Shell,
you will see that
under image with v3,
we have this workflow.yaml that
where the workflow is defined,
OK?
So let's take a look
at that, actually,
in a little bit more
detail, because that's
kind of the meat
of the code lab,
how to bring these services
together with workflow.
So if you look at
this workflow.yaml,
you will see that
now in this workflow,
we are defining how services
should be called, right?
But first thing
that we need to do
is that who's going to
trigger this workflow?
You can either execute it
yourself, but in our case,
we're going to have events from
Eventarc executing it, right?
So that's why we have
this first parameter
event indicating
that this workflow is
going to receive an event.
It's actually a Cloud
event from Eventarc.
Right.
And then after that we
define steps, what should
happen in this orchestration?
The first step is
called log events,
so we just log the
event that we received,
just to see what we have
is useful for debugging.
And then next step, we were
extracting the information
that we need from event.
So we are extracting the bucket
and the name from the event.
So this event is going
to be a file storage
event from Cloud Storage
with the bucket and the name,
so we're just extracting
that and assigning them
to this variables bucket
and file variable, OK?
Then the next step is filter.
So in this step, we are
making an HTTP post call
to filter URL.
Now, this filter URL, it's
a placeholder right now.
We need to replace that
with the actual filter URL
that we saved from
our Cloud Function.
So that's why I say I have
this to do, replace here,
and we'll do that
in the next step.
But we will make a call
to that filter URL.
And then the body
of this HTTP post,
we will pass in the
bucket and the file
that we receive from
the event, right?
So we are basically
saying to the filter,
just filter this file
in this bucket for us.
The filter will have
a response, and we'll
capture that response
in filter response.
So that's what this is about.
Now, the next step
is to log the safety,
so the filter response
will have the body
and the body will
have a JSON that
will say safe, true or false.
So we're just logging that
just so that we can see.
And then after we log it, we
need to actually check it.
So this check safety
actually checks the response
in the body and the safe
and see if it's true.
If it's true, then it will
continue with label step,
so the label step is
the next step, right?
It will just continue there.
But if it's false, meaning
the picture is not safe,
then the next step is end,
meaning this orchestration will
end, right?
So we check the safety.
If it's not safe, we
just finish there.
We don't do anything else.
And then the next
step after this
is that now that we
know the image is safe,
we call the labeler function.
Again, the labeler
URL is the placeholder
that we will replace, and we
pass in the bucket and the file
information, and then
we save the response
of this labeler function
in the labeler response.
Then we call the resizer,
again with the resizer URL
and with bucket and
file, and we save
the response and
the resize response,
right, so very similar.
And finally, we call
the watermark function.
Now, with the
watermark function,
we pass in more information.
We pass in the bucket, the
file of the resize image.
So you can see that
we are getting that
from the resize response,
so we are getting it
from this resize call So
that's the resize image bucket
and file.
And we also get the labels
from the label response,
so from the label function.
So the response that we get
from resize and the response
that we get from label, we pass
that to our watermark function,
and the watermark
will do its work
and it will return a
response, as well, OK?
And then finally, we have
a final step in this step.
We are just returning a JSON
of filter, label, resize,
and watermark, where we
just return this HTTP status
code from each service, just
to see that if they work.
I mean, you could return
anything else you want.
You could return the URL
of the image if you like,
or something else, but here I'm
just returning the HTTP code
from each service.
So you see how
nicely we can define
what should happen in
what order and what
happens with the
response and how
you pass the response from
one step to another step,
things like that.
That's what workflow
is good for.
All right, so we are in step 9.
We check the workflow, and here
I'm explaining what each do,
but I already did that to you.
But what we need to do is we
need to deploy this workflow.
So we are in image-v3
folder, I believe.
Yes, we are.
So to deploy it--
well, before we
deploy it, we need
to change this, the URLs, these
placeholders with actual URLs.
And remember, we saved these
URLs as we went along, right,
so we had a call, for example,
if I do a call filter URL,
you see that I have
the actual URL.
So we need to change them.
You can manually change them
in workflow.yaml, if you like,
but you can also use sed.
So this what I'm
going to do here.
I'm just going to use sed.
And if I do Git
diff, actually, you
can see that our workflow
changed and the placeholders
are changed with actual
URLs of the functions, which
is what I want.
And then once we do that,
to deploy the workflow,
we just say gcloud workflow
is deployed, give it a name,
in this case, image processing.
And then we point to our source
and we point to our region.
So this is it.
This is how we
deploy the workflow.
And it's quite quick, actually.
Within a few seconds,
it should be deployed.
But this deploys the workflow,
but it doesn't actually run it.
Now, if we go to
workflows, we should
see that there is this
image processing workflow
but there is no execution of it.
Nothing triggered this yet,
because we didn't set that up
yet.
But if we go to source--
let's make this a
little bit bigger--
if you go to source, you
can see our definition.
But also, you can see
this visualization
where it shows you in this
workflow, we log the event,
we filter it, we
check for safety.
If it's not safe, we finish.
But if it's safe,
we continue, right?
So it's very useful
to kind of visualize
what's happening in workflow.
All right, so our
orchestration, let's
go back to architecture
review again.
So we are basically here where
we deployed the services.
We put them together
into an orchestration.
And the last step is to actually
connect this orchestration
to an event from Cloud Storage.
And we'll do that using
Eventarc Cloud Storage trigger.
So it will-- that Eventarc will
be used to make the connection.
So that's step 10.
Now, in Eventarc,
there's one time setup.
So you need to--
first of all, you need
have a service account
that has Eventarc
event receiver role.
And you'll use this
service account
to when you create a trigger.
You need to have
a service account.
You have two choices.
You can actually create
a service account
and give it to this
Eventarc receiver role,
or you can use the default
compute service account that
comes with every project,
and just make sure
that it has this role.
So in this case, I'm
just using the default
compute service
account, so first,
let's get the project
number because you need that
for the service account name.
So let me make this bigger.
Let's clear this.
So let's get the project number.
And then here, we are
adding a policy binding
and we are just saying
that this service account
with this project number, that
-compute, this is the default
compute service account, will
have the role, Eventarc event
receiver.
So we are making sure
that it has this role.
And since we are using
Cloud Storage trigger here,
we also need to make sure
that the Cloud Storage
service account, there's also
a default service account
for that has pubsub publisher
role for it, as well, OK?
And so I'll just, again,
copy and paste this.
This is the default service
account for Cloud Storage,
and then let's make sure that we
have a policy binding for that.
And it has pubsub
publisher role.
Now, this is a one time setup.
So once you do this
once in your project,
you don't have to do it again.
But since we are
using a new project,
I want to make sure that
we have this set up.
OK, now that we have that, how
do we connect Cloud Storage
events to workflows?
Well, we do that through what's
called an Eventarc trigger.
So let me copy and
paste this, and then I
will explain what this does.
So this creates a trigger,
and let's look at the details,
basically.
So we are saying
that I want to create
a trigger with
this name, which is
going to be trigger, dash,
my workflow name, image
processing.
By the way, it's failed.
So let's-- sometimes
it just fails.
Let me run this one more
time, see what happens.
OK, so now it's
creating the trigger.
So we are saying that
we want to create
a trigger in this region,
which is US central.
And I want these events to go
to a workflow with this name,
image processing,
and this workflow
using this location, US
central, because everything
is localizing Google Cloud.
So that's why we need
to specify the region.
And then we also have
some event filters.
So we don't want all the
events to go to workflow.
We only want events
from this bucket,
which is the input bucket,
to our workflow input bucket
that we are interested in.
And then we also don't want all
the events from this bucket.
We only want object
finalize events.
So this is the object
finalize event,
which gets triggered when
you save a new object.
So if someone
saves a new object,
you want that to trigger.
But otherwise, we don't
care about other events.
And we also pass in
the service account.
So this created the trigger
after the second try.
I don't know what
happened in the first one.
But if you go to Eventarc,
we should see the trigger,
see trigger image processing,
and destination is a workflow.
And it's actually targeting
image processing workflow, OK?
So everything seems
to be working--
well, not working,
but at least set up.
So in step 11, let's just
test out whether this works.
And to test it out, all
we need to do is deploy--
well, upload a picture and
see that it's processed.
So what we're going
to do is we're
can go to-- we can use
gsutil to upload an image,
but let's do it from the UI.
So I go to Cloud Storage,
and I see my input and output
buckets.
So let's go to input bucket.
You see there is no images here.
I will upload a
picture of myself.
And now, as this is uploading,
let's actually go to workflows
and see what happens.
So if you go to workflows,
click on the workflow,
image processing.
You see that there's
an execution now
that's active, right?
So the uploading of the
image triggered an event
through Eventarc, and that
event is now in workflows
and the workflow is now
working through that event.
And if you click
in the execution--
and it's already succeeded
at it, by the way,
so it's pretty quick.
But if you look at the inputs
and outputs of the execution,
you see that this is the
input that it receives.
So this is the event that it
received from Google Cloud
Storage, with the bucket
and data and the information
about the image.
And this is the output
that workflows did.
So the output is what
we kind of produced,
filter service, label service,
resize service, and watermark
service, they all
returned 200, HTTP 200,
meaning they all worked fine.
So it seems like
things are working.
And if you look at
the logs, we see
that the event is being
logged, and also the safety,
whether the image is
safe or not is logged.
And if we-- let's do one more
image, just for the fun of it.
Let's upload a beach, a
more interesting picture
with sunshine and things.
So let's upload that, and
this will trigger, as well.
And then just to check
that things are working,
if we go to this
output bucket, you
see that we have
three different files.
So first, Atamel--
so this was my image.
So we have a labels.txt.
And if we look at
this labels.txt,
these are all the labels that
was picked up by Vision API.
So it says forehead, cheek,
smiles, so that sounds like me.
Then if you look at 400x400
PNG, that's the resize image.
So you see that it's squeezed
a little bit, maybe not
the right way of resizing,
but it's definitely resized.
And then if you look at
the 400x400 watermark,
you see that it's the resize
image with the top three
labels added as a watermark.
So it seems like
everything is working.
And then the other picture, the
beach one is more interesting.
You see that it says
water, cloud, sky, again,
the same kind of
thing from there.
So this concludes our code lab.
You've seen how to combine
an event-driven and an
orchestrated
architecture into one.
Hopefully, this
was useful to you.
Feel free to reach
out to me on Twitter
if you have any
questions or feedback.
Thanks very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]